Speaker 1: Let's go next. Where are
we going next? Let's talk to Oz from
Kentucky Oz. It's been a while. What's going on?
Speaker 3: Hello, David, can you hear me? Yes,
I can. Oh, what's been going on? I'm so
happy that I was able to get through,
so I decided to run for U.S. House of
Representatives here as an independent. OK,
and my Kentucky, for which I'll be running
against Thomas Massie. That's who my
representative is. Mm-Hmm. And I've got the
signatures required to get on the ballot,
and I'll be going to Frankfurt to file this
week. And I have a website which is Oz 20
22 us, which has my bio and platform on it.
Speaker 1: How many signatures do you need
or I mean, what I mean is I know you got them,
but how many signatures did you need to collect?
Speaker 3: Four hundred. OK, I have about
100, I was going to try to get a thousand
just because the more the better, but I'm just
running out of time. Got to have some other man.
I'm working on that I haven't been able to focus
on because I've been trying to get these and
it's been really tough because I've only been
doing it like one day a week when I'm off work
right to get signatures. And it's not. Yeah,
I do that. A similar, you know, I work for a
union and I do similar things for the union and
in community organizing, but it is dangerous.
I was a or had people try to assault me two
different times while I was out. Canvasing. Why?
Speaker 1: Why would just collecting
signatures made them want to assault you?
Speaker 3: Well, the first one happened actually
on Christmas Eve was when I started the whole
thing of getting signatures, and the first one
was just like a random, crazy, like crackhead guy.
And he was shirtless and it was probably like
40 degrees out on Christmas Eve and we were
in front of a church. Hmm. And then he came up
and he started harassing these elderly people
and was trying to get into the church. And then he
started yelling at me, and then he ran up. And I
happen to have bear spray like within arm's reach,
and he had blasted him in the face with it and was
able to repel. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So,
all right, well, it sounds like a lot
is happening, what's I don't want you to
give me your full platform, but what's your
main issue going to be for your campaign?
Speaker 3: Well, the main issue is taking
control of Kentucky's natural resources,
and I want to see coal and everything in water
and other natural resources socialized or
nationalized. I prefer the term socialized because
it's a little different, but people here don't
really. That's a hot word, but I try to avoid
buzz words like that to trigger people in the not
wanting to listen. But. Sure. And people like
oligarchs like Mitch McConnell control this.
The natural resources here for 40 years and
they've been pillaging of state. And these natural
resources belong to everyone, and they should
be used to enrich the lives of the citizens,
not line the pockets of the oligarchs. So that's
one thing. And you know, I'm for criminal justice
reform is at the top of my list by myself being
in recovery and being through the system. I know
how corrupt it is. I want to see the change
to the system. Systemic problems that we have
with our criminal justice system. And, well, those
Speaker 1: are worthy causes as those are two. I
know we don't have time for every campaign point.
Are you are you thinking of a slogan? I think you
could play off of Dr. Oz and kind of be like, I'm
the odds that won't recommend drinking silver or
something like that. That could be cool.
Speaker 3:
I'll say that Twitter a big enough for both
of us when it comes to Dr. Oz, just like
slogans, get smart Kentucky, because Kentucky
needs to get smart and stop electing these
people that are oppressing them, right?
Speaker 1: Wow. Well, Oz, we wish you the absolute
best of luck. Keep us posted on the campaign. OK?
Speaker 3: 2020 to date us. Please check
it out. You. All right.
Speaker 1: There it is.
Long time caller Oz is running. They said
to him, Sir, will you run? And I said, Yes,
I will. So you guys can check that out. Let's take
a very quick break. We're going to go right back
to the phones after this short break. So don't
go anywhere if you're holding on to talk to me.